you can get things done um
the most valuable thing though that you
get when
when you're on when you've got the
players here that you can't get
virtually
is uh the on-field experience and being
able to teach
willy gay coming in as a rookie how to
move and
drop and your fundamentals and
techniques the different coverages that
he's got to take care of
run fit responsibilities when you're not
hands on
it's hard to walk through those things
and so
um you end up retarding the
the um the first
first year player second third year
player a bit
uh by heaven uh by only being able to do
it virtually you know that
that's uh that ends up being a bit of an
issue the other part comes in
is being able to put new things in so
without exhausting it and again without
coaches taking
advantage of situations i think that's
also important
you're able to give give the players
some new thoughts that through all this
scheme evolve that you discuss with them
hey listen let's try this let's just
take a look at it let's see
let's see what it looks like if it's no
good we can throw it out there rather
than wasting time during training camp
[Music]
coaches are not allowed to say anything
that would suggest that voluntary
offseason workouts are anything but
voluntary there is no prohibition
however in the collective bargaining
agreement
on explaining the virtues of choosing to
show up
a very carefully worded explanation from
andy reid saying nothing
about the workouts being anything other
than voluntary but making it very clear
why it makes sense for players to show
up and the chiefs one of the four teams
that aren't even getting squeezed by the
union to stay away
because they use workout bonuses so
aggressively in their contracts the
players
have to be there and we said this
yesterday i think more and more teams
are going to be using these workout
bonuses to avoid this issue in the
future
i i would imagine so i mean i think
there's a lot of benefits one you know
of course hey yeah you want your guys
there to work
and do like what andy reid said all
those all those things he said are very
real you know the other aspect too is
you know
being there in the locker room and being
together it starts kind of the lifeline
of the football team
it starts the culture of the football
team together you start to build
and you know start your own you know
lifeline for this hey it's our 2021 team
here's the new guys and all that and
we're together and
we're all for this main goal that gets
lost in this whole thing as well
but the on the field work like we've hit
on a few times mike
that's that's really the biggest thing
and especially the young football
players
yeah i know tyrone matthew knows you
know
what to do and every coverage and the
proper techniques and all that
but they're still like andy said you
know any guy under four years in the nfl
he's still
learning and there's lot lots to be you
know learned still and
a lot of those guys are behind the eight
ball especially first year guys who are
going to year two
where they never really had that base
you know instilled in them last year
they kind of learned on the fly
and you know that's again where i would
worry about you know the whole situation
with the young players and the current
environment we got
there's an old saying that goes wisdom
off and never shows up at all
it's better if it arrives late this idea
that it's taken the union 20 plus years
to get to the point where they recognize
there's
muscle to be flexed in staying away or
trying to get players to stay away
from the off season program i just think
that there's a disconnect between
getting ready for football season and
taking a stand i think it's too late to
take that stand
and make it work because what it's
ultimately going to do
it's going to create a competitive
advantage this year for the teams
whose players show up chiefs packers
jaguars
bills four teams that have heavy workout
bonuses
they're going to be there they're going
to get the advantage of it
and we're going to see this year and and
it's going to be a dotted line it's not
going to be a clear line
but if all four of those teams make the
playoffs now three of them we expect to
anyway if the jaguars all of a sudden
are dramatically better
because their players are there and they
aren't being pressured by the union to
have their players stay away
then then it is an apples-to-apples
comparison between the teams
that are all in and the teams that are
either sporadic yeah or the guys aren't
showing up at all but even
even the teams that are saying we're not
going to be there at all they're still
going to be guys there
they're still going to be there dolphins
players were there yesterday right not
all of them
but they're going to be there guys
understand it's in their individual
interest to be there no matter what the
union may be trying to do
and it's going to be very difficult to
get a huge percentage of guys
to go against their own individual
interest for something like this
i i think so i mean i would have a hard
time i know
just you know whether i was a starter or
a backup i wouldn't be able to stay away
i'd be too worried about what was being
done who was passing me by who was
learning new tricks and new plays
what's going on that way that would
drive me crazy that wouldn't be any cool
for a person like me and i think there's
a lot of people like that in the nfl
where you know it's type a like
obsessive compulsive i like this
schedule this is what i do
type personalities yeah they're not
going to be cool with like you know
doing stuff
at home and all that they're gonna want
to be there in the mix the personal
interactions all of that type of stuff
i mean that that that is real and you
know mike i think you bring up a good
point too about like
you know the advantages and
disadvantages i think we'll see you know
teams that have great leadership or
great leaders who are going to
attend you know these workouts and maybe
uh have the the right players all
together
i think that's gonna like let's just say
cam newton
he went in yesterday right new england
uh that's gonna filter throughout their
team
right so they're not i might not
everybody been there yesterday but now a
few defensive guys who were there
they're going to tell some other
defensive guys hey we were there cam was
there it was a good day we worked
and you're going to see and those type
of scenarios where the main leaders of
the football team are there
slowly but surely i think the majority
of the team to your point is gonna start
to gravitate towards there
you know maybe the the superstars of the
team again that no they don't have to be
there
and they're they know they've been
around their techniques everything
they're secure in the roster all that
okay yeah they might not be there but i
think slowly
but surely as this goes this offseason
you're gonna see more and more guys
start to show up because they're gonna
realize what the hell else am i doing
and why am i cheating myself in the long
run
and putting yourself in position where
if your coach
is upset about what's going on
there will be there gonna be some
consequences yes
where it can't be proven right
it can't be shown right can't be
detected
but hey 90 goes down to 53
labor day weekend we want volunteers not
hostages
that's right and the guys who are acting
like hostages are the guys who
are going to be freed when the time
comes to set the 53-man roster
potentially now if you're good enough
you can get away with it but that's
always been the case
the superstars come and go as they
please nobody ever says
boo right it's when you fall into that
range of
and we got two or three guys all doing
the same job and they're all relatively
the same from a talent standpoint
this guy's expensive exactly this guy
isn't right that's when you got yourself
a problem
exactly right that's gonna be those
scenarios where it's like hey this guy
we don't have a clear-cut stud star
player
at this position we got two or three
guys who are pretty good
oh wait these two guys were here and
have been here and doing everything
they're gonna get the advantages they're
gonna get the advantage when training
camp comes around and otas they are
that's what's going to happen you're
right there's going to be no way to
prove it
but they're going to be thrown out there
with the starters they're going to give
be given an extra chance to fail if they
do things like that
and if they can capitalize and take
advantage of that opportunity the job
will be theirs i i have a hard time
thinking
again i know coaches are humans and they
understand how serious it was
last year and everything like that and
everything about it
but still coaches are psychos in the way
of yeah the way they think about
football their job we
i go to work this is what i do i expect
you to do it with me
and that's the way they're wired and i
think that you know back to that mike
tomlin quote when you
when you act like you're you know being
held hostage
the coaching the coaching world doesn't
love that they want guys who love to be
around football and love to play it
just like they do and uh i think there
is something to that and those guys are
going to be in trouble who who weren't
around
i think so much of this is a pr play by
the union it seems like it
it's it's a successful one to a certain
extent they've managed to have
drips and drabs of statements they
didn't do them all at once
it's hey this team issues a statement
about off-season workouts then four
hours later this team does and they
spread it out over five or six days
we got stories covering every single one
of them once you start you can't stop
so they they've commanded multiple news
cycles with it
and they're blaming on the pandemic and
nobody i don't think anybody really
believes
about the pandemic but still from a pr
standpoint it works
and meanwhile you got guys showing up
the guy showing up
won't resonate the same way as the
statement did
for every statement from a team you get
a headline oh
cam newton showed up oh drew locke what
a shock drew lock who
who is worried about his career right
drew lock shows up
cowboys players who had a meeting six
days ago about this
and never issued a statement and never
said a word right
they're showing up yeah they saw jerry's
that part of it's not going to be
publicized
right the statements are and maybe
that's the win the union was looking for
because they know they ultimately aren't
going to keep these guys away
not 100 not even close to 100 no way no
way you're right
hey listen we already brought up two
names drew lock cam newton it's a big
year for them of course they're there
they got to be there you know i can
speak from my own personal experience
i got thrown into the fray as maybe
being a starter going into my second
year
because i know i impressed gruden with
my off-season work
you know on days when people weren't
there i was there throwing at garbage
cans doing drills outside
you know i'd have people telling me hey
he was in the facility watching you work
through the windows he was saying a lot
of good things about you and all that
type of stuff
you know so those these are the
opportunities you have if your players
like drew lock or whatever else
you can impress your coaches here's
another aspect i want to bring up to you
mike just to get your thought on this
some of these guys too who decide not to
show up for work and come to otas and do
that
you know and it's you know safety coven
19 still hasn't been you know under
control here in the nfl facilities
whatever blah blah blah
but the other aspect i do if like if
some of these teams with these guys who
are not showing up
if they start to hear that they're out
at the club or they're at the beach
and they're at other big gatherings with
other people
you know i just wonder the effect that's
gonna have on the nfl pa
the teams some of these players and all
that too like the players better watch
it you better not be out in public
like messing around and then claiming we
don't feel safe to go to the facility
like that that's not going to be a good
look for the players
no i agree with you guys out doing
things without masks on guys not getting
vaccinated and then fundamentally
what concerns do you have about the same
protocols you agreed to
last year during the entire season and
nobody ever complained about
the protocols then other than when there
was an outbreak and some players didn't
feel safe in baltimore
for justifiable reasons the day-in and
day-out grind of the way the protocols
worked as agreed to by the union in the
league
nobody ever said hey you know what i
feel like i'm stepping into a petri dish
every day i show up for work no nobody
ever said anything
about it because as you said all year
long last year even though it's not
a popular position the truth is most of
these guys just don't care yeah so don't
tell me you care
a year later we know you don't care and
if you do care
show me your vaccination card yeah it's
that simple yeah you're right it is it's
that simple there's no doubt so we'll
see where this goes i think that's going
to be kind of a secretly
kind of fun thing to watch this off
season a little bit i think we'll hear
more and more rumors and things of teams
being disappointed or mad guys didn't
show up and stuff like that as we go
along here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports